so we've talked a bit about what our
tool needs to be able to do what tools
are out there for us to use most people
who make prototypes for living work with
a lot of tools and many of them are very
well tailored for a particular kind of
prototype some of the tools people use
our keynote PowerPoint interactive PDFs
balsamic pixate envision and our good
old pen and paper don't worry about
trying to remember all of these the
point is to give you a sense of what's
out there in the next video we'll talk
about what tool will be using for this
lesson and why each of these tools has
various strengths and weaknesses and
each of them will become apart of a
mature prototyper toolkit let's get a
sense of how each tool matches up with
our requirements right now keynote is a
common tool for when you want to present
a low fidelity prototype to a group
often within your company it's very fast
to work with but it's hard to get remote
feedback with and is non interactive
PowerPoint is a very similar tool and
it's used for the same reasons again
speed is a strength here but there is no
built-in feedback and it's not
interactive interactive pdfs made with
adobe indesign are common choice for
designers who are workshopping user
experiences they are interactive and
once you put in the work to learn the
software can be made relatively quickly
however they have no remote feedback
options balsamic with a Q is one of the
faster prototyping tools which allows
for easy iteration but doesn't have
built in remote feedback tools some
people combine balsamic with a user
testing framework to handle that portion
pixate is a prototyping software
targeted at high fidelity prototyping it
does interactions and a lot of its power
is in the way it deals with micro
interactions and animations we'll
revisit pixate in the next lesson for
now it's a bit slow for our purposes
invision allows you to create
interactive prototypes quickly and has a
couple of dedicated tools for getting
remote feedback quickly and effectively
and finally our old friend the pen and
paper is super fast but doesn't allow
remote feedback and it doesn't allow
interactivity